there seems to be no end in sight to the
protests in Hong Kong and no sign that
the government is willing to bow to any
of the protesters demands but in a
conversation with business leaders that
was leaked to the media the city's chief
executive indicated she wanted to walk
away fasting is two hours later in her
weekly media conference Carrie Lam said
it was unacceptable that the private
conversation had been recorded and she
sought to clarify her comments about
resigning
I have never I have never attended a
resonation to the central People's
Government I have not even contemplated
to discuss a resonation with the central
People's Government the choice of not
resigning is my own choice the
resignation of the chief executive was
one of the key demands of the protesters
when they began taking to the streets
their rally started when the government
tried to introduce an extradition bill
which would have allowed criminal
suspects to be sent to mainland China
for trial Carrie Lam says the bill is
dead the protesters want her to
officially withdraw at the leaked
comments from Carrie Lam come just days
after another media report suggested
that the central government in China had
rejected a proposal by her to withdraw
the extradition bill the report claimed
that Beijing ordered her not to agree to
any of the protesters demands
she also said in the leaked audio that
the government in Beijing has no plans
to put soldiers on the streets of Hong
Kong to try to end the crisis and that
her power is particularly limited at the
moment because of the trade war between
China and the United States
executive who unfortunately has to serve
two masters by Constitution as a central
People's Government and the people honk
off that political manoeuvring it's very
ear are already allegations that Carrie
Lam leaked the audio herself to try to
ease the pressure on her which she says
is not true the controversy is likely to
have little impact on the situation with
both sides no closer to finding a
resolution Wayne hey al Jazeera Hong
Kong